the general manager of the kansas city
chiefs the defending afc champion kansas
city chiefs
uh brett veach back here on the rich
eisen show how are you brett
rich i'm doing great how are you doing
how you guys doing we're doing fine we
are doing fine
um so what do you think of that opener
chiefs uh yeah that's gonna be a tough
one coming around the gate uh certainly
we had our hands
full with them in the playoffs and um
they've done a great job in regards to
their off season
and then out in town for their secondary
and um
look they're gonna be a tough game we're
certainly excited to to get this thing
kicked off hopefully we have a full
capacity crowd there and
capitalizing that whole field advantage
and do you have the schedule yet
do you have it you can tell me you know
i'm not gonna pry because you know i'm
the host of that show i don't even have
it yet they're they don't even trust me
and i'm a vault
i'm like a seinfeld do you have it yet
do you know
so i do okay but you know how this works
they
they give you the email um with about 30
warnings
that if you leak it there'll be serious
ramifications so
i can't say this though there's only
three people i think that have the
schedule in our department that would be
myself coach reed and eric stonestreet
so you can do
at least protect me a little bit here
sure so i don't get in trouble um
any information you need chief related
just just give eric a text and
and that way we'll keep it clean i don't
know brett who
eric would be more uh concerned about
alienating by leaking it you and the
chief's organization or his bff
rg1 roger goodell i don't know i think
he's gonna
i think he's gonna sit on this
information brett i'll be honest with
him
i think he got the schedule before i did
you know we were talking about week one
he's like yeah new weeks ago so
i think he's ahead of me in regards to
rg one's uh priority list so who should
he ask him or you uh
when's that game against jordan love and
the packers brett
when's that one oh listen like i said
eric has that type of information and um
i'm sure he'll be happy to share with
you
oh man but that is so i i look because
we all know what the browns did last
year and they added clowny
to the mix on the defensive line that
will be quite the first test for your
revamped offensive line i would say for
sure walk me through your um
your timeline here on rebuilding your
offensive line
and um and and um we were all we all saw
the super bowl
and and we were all talking about it i'm
wondering if it hits you in the same way
clearly yeah well i think it was kind of
one of those situations where when we
start coming as the staff
in in october november just looking
ahead to free agency and and roster
construction in the future
certainly the offensive line was was on
the forefront um
in regards to our agenda and what we
want to get accomplished now um
during that time we proceeded to lose
our starting right tackle ms schwartz
and then in the af championship game our
left tackle eric fisher so
i would say that the offensive line was
already at the forefront
of what we wanted to get done but that
certain that that plan certainly got
expedited
um and it got put into high gear once
we were kind of uh made aware that you
know these
you know we'll see what happens with
mitch schwartz and and his return and i
know eric just signed with the colts but
um you know both those guys um haven't
played a bunch of
snaps in the league and and just wanting
to continue to build youth and depth on
on our roster was was something that we
were um
going in that direction anyway so it
just got kind of put in ultra gear there
and
and you know it was it's always
dangerous when you go into free agency
uh we were
fortunate enough to knock out the great
interior player and joe tuney right off
the bat
um exercised a little patience and the
orlando brown thing worked out
and then you know then once you're not
really going out there trying to
assemble a roster by knee and you're
letting value and players come to you i
feel like everything else just kind of
fell in place in regards to
adding young players like creed humphrey
and trey smith in the draft
so um let's let me pull on that string a
little bit on orlando brown where you
said
uh having you know patience paying off
a little bit what what do you mean by
that just knocking on the door of the
ravens and
and um what do you mean by that well
i i think when you go into freight and
say you know we had a plan
and and we wanted to certainly add an
interior player and
and a tackle and and as i mentioned we
we cranked out joe tuning right off the
bat and
we um we were kind of in on trent
williams a little bit and he decided to
stay in san francisco
and then after that i mean there's many
different avenues you can pursue and
there were some other players available
but
i think when we looked at our roster and
looking at the draft and trying to
you know marry the two um pools of of
players
you know we weren't really extremely
driven by what else was out there
on the free asian side um we kind of did
our homework in the draft and
talked about moving up and and acquiring
you know
maybe moving down and acquiring more
assets and and acquiring more than one
tackle and
we kind of just were patient and i don't
think we panicked and just signed the
next tackle on the board which is where
we're looking for a specific criteria
and we really just wanted a legitimate
starting left tackle so
um whether we had to move up in the
draft or just be patient and see how
things play out with other players
was the direction we decided to go in
and a few weeks later as we got closer
to the draft
um conversations with baltimore start to
pick up and we were able to pull that
trade off so
um you know it was one of those deals
where we had a plan and
we executed part one of the plan and and
we just had to be patient and wait and
fortunately for us
orlando became available and we were
able to um you know to finalize the deal
with him and get him here so we're
extremely excited about that the reason
why i asked about
your patience remark uh brett is because
i was wondering because we we did have
john harbaugh on the show
before the draft and i asked him if he
was if there was any hesitancy on the
ravens
side of of you know trading a player who
clearly wanted to be a left tackle and
wanted out because of that because of
ronnie stanley there and
if there was any hesitancy with trading
with the team that's won the the
conference the last two years
and he said no because the the deal was
right but i'm wondering if
if there was any hesitancy that you
noticed until you had to actually
make the deal right for the ravens from
your perspective yeah i mean
listen possibly you know those trades
are always
tricky um just because it
the market is select that you know
obviously orlando's
a great tackle um it was made clear
early on
after the offseason began that he wanted
to play left tackle i think that they
had a unique relationship
in regards to orlando and his family
history with that organization so i
truly believe it was a situation where
they were
wanting best of both parties but when
you look at the landscape of the nfl and
you have a great player who wants to
play left tackle you're going to have a
certain amount of teams that already
have
really good left tackles and then you're
going to have a certain amount of teams
that are picking high in the draft and
they may want to just draft one early to
get
five years of contractual control so it
kind of narrows
the pull when you're trying to do
something like this it's not like you
have 32 teams
just um having an opening uh
in caps basement and what have you so i
think we got a little lucky
um i don't think it was their desire to
trade him to the chiefs i think
it just worked out where it made sense
for both parties kansas city chiefs gm
brett vich here
on the rich eisen show how is patrick
mahomes and his
foot how is he right now he's doing good
and it's
typical with patrick we're going to have
to protect patrick versus himself
because
he's already i spoke to him a few days
ago and he's ahead of schedule and
and um look he's going to do some stuff
at these otas it won't be
um full drawbacks and rollouts but he'll
he'll do some stuff i spoke with rick
burkholder our trainer you know we have
our rookies in this week so we're super
excited about
getting our coaches with them and
actually getting some field work with
them but
when i spoke to rick and to coach about
you know teams always bring in some
extra quarterback arms for camp and
you know our trainer said to me he's
like no that's going to do some stuff
this
this ota uh these faiths during the otas
now
we're not going to be crazy with him
we'll be super smart but he's ahead of
schedule and
we'll probably get a little taste of of
him back in action
very light during the otas but i expect
him to be full goal for training him
when's the first time you laid eyes on
him and give me a good story about when
you realized he was special
different first time oh oh shoot um
so i think i uh told the story a couple
times but
i mean it was way back in the day so
when patrick before he even declared i
think
every summer and spring nfl personal
departments get their list of
of you know seniors to watch from
our scouting system in our program so we
were just kind of going through the
exercises and
at the time i believe i was looking at
offensive alignment prospects and
texas tech had a had a prospect that was
dropped eligible the following year and
you know during may and june just kind
of peeking at this
left tackle prospect and all of a sudden
this sophomore quarterback was
just ripping stuff up up and down the
field and every game you're watching i
quickly realized that i wasn't watching
the guy was supposed to be watching
which was the left tackle prospect i was
watching the sophomore quarterback
then you start googling and researching
and where the kids from
and and what he did the year before got
a couple vlogs uh starts
as a freshman and then um as you quickly
start watching more and more tape you
get to this bowl game i think he played
lsu a sophomore year and
single-handedly kept the team in the
game and they were completely outmatched
in regards to talent on both sides of
the football but
uh he was just cutting it loose and
doing what he does now on sundays and
and it was one of those deals where um i
don't know if it was later that day or
the next day coach
happened to walk by the office and i
joked with him i said hey here's the
next quarterback of the chief and
we look back and laugh at it now but uh
yeah it was really
one of those accidental exercises where
you're watching somebody else and
and this sophomore quarterback uh from
texas tech kind of
draws your attention and you just kind
of get fascinated by the things you can
do on the field and
uh fortunately for us it worked out and
you know we got him here and
we surrounded him with a lot of talent
and some great coaches and
it's been all uphill ever since no
question no doubt about i mean dream
come true and brett you're
you're a perfect person to ask this
question to here because
uh the all throughout the pre-draft
and of course the post draft after the
season was over too
the conversation begins about how do you
build a team around a quarterback in the
nfl or how do you build a championship
team in the nfl
do you add a quarterback who's a veteran
and certainly now that we've had 10
years of the new way of doing things
since the
two collective bargain agreements ago
blew up the way that you paid
rookies right and then you you you had
to make a determination on a first round
rookie with a fifth year pick up and
things of that nature
that you want to win a super bowl in the
first iteration
of a player's contract because you can
pay other people because they're
somewhat affordable before you have to
decide
to give them the monster contract and
and and then so we've seen a team do
that
with a player and then we've seen them
also pick up a fifth year option of
somebody
and then kind of lament that after
giving a nine figure deal to somebody
we've seen once traded we've seen golf
traded we've seen
you know uh brady uh being picked up and
we saw obviously what tampa was able to
do you see what's going on in green bay
with what aaron rodgers is hoping to
have built around him
you're the only team that was able to
win with the guy in the first year
first iteration of a contract and be
absolutely
fully confident that the next contract
with nine figures on it is just
all good how do you think nfl teams
are going to look at building a team
around a quarterback are they going to
draft one and stick with them
are they going to eventually draft one
and then trade them out to start the
clock again
are they going to go veteran what do you
think the rest of the league is thinking
right now brett vich well i mean that's
a great question i i
certainly think that the natural
inclination would be to draft and extend
it
and you know i i think it there is that
challenge of
you know roster construction and and
being right on draft and being right on
your free agency
takes a little bit of of luck in regards
to players staying healthy
and the amount of picks you have in
certain years and how you're able to um
to work these contracts out certainly
you know we had
a great relationship with with pat and
his agent
and it was important for us um you know
to get this deal done but to also add
flexibility so that
we could a take care of him and pay him
the way he needs to be paid
but also be provide that flexibility so
that we can continually add
talent and and have that roster
maneuverability so i think
uh the natural inclination would be to
to draft and extend
with some flexibility you know within
that extension
it's tough i think that's the dream
scenario uh certainly very hard now
there's a lot of things that come into
play but i think if you asked any jam i
think that their
goal would be to draft one and by the
third or fourth year extend them um with
some flexibility building there they can
continue to add talent
um it just doesn't always work out that
way so i think we really
we realize here that um you know we
certainly have a special set up and
we're very thankful and grateful for
that
yeah i mean you're the only one who's
been able to do it brett honestly i mean
you know
i guess russell might be one um but he
you know
he he just got drafted the year after
this all started with the new
uh collective bargaining agreement and
so russell was able to do that they've
gone on their second contract
but so few teams have been able to do
what you are what you're doing i mean
that's the ultimate gold rush that
you've done right here or
unless you know you can pick up a 43
year old quarterback who plays the way
that brady does
that's just such an anomaly do you think
though
that we will see one day a team draft
one
and then like college let him graduate
and then start the clock again do you
ever think we will see something like
that in the nfl and say the next 10
years now that we have a new
cba on that front right yeah i mean i
guess you could but
i mean it's hard because everything has
to line up
so i guess your question is you get a
quarterback you let it play out and you
draft another one well
i mean where are you picking how many
quarterbacks are available in the draft
are you picking
uh i mean certainly you don't only pick
him in the top ten every year because
you're not very good and that would mean
the quarterback didn't play very
good so it's one of those fine lines
where
if you have success of with a rookie
quarterback on his rookie deal
you're picking 30 31 well how many true
surefire
plug-in play starters do you think you
know are you're going to have access to
right so then if you do let them go and
you're picking 31 i mean who are you
going to get there 31. so it's a fine
line and
it's it's tricky now if all of a sudden
years from now
down the line there's this influx of 8
nine ten quarterbacks going year after
year
that's possible i just think that it's
very hard to land one of these guys and
teams that get stuck in in purgatory so
to speak are teams that have
quarterbacks that are just good enough
and they're picking 19 or 20 and the
quarterbacks are going in the top 10 and
they're kind of like
their guy's okay but they want to get
better and it's just hard so
it's kind of like a dog chasing his tail
so i just think that it's extremely
difficult and hard to predict
who will be available to you if you let
someone with a lot of talent go so i
guess your challenge is is to with the
cost certainty that you have relatively
with your quarterback with that
long-term deal is to figure out when the
other
dynamic players that you have on your
team are up
so you can pay them and keep them
assuming the cap does go up that's
essentially what your
your balance sheet looks like for the
chiefs yeah here yeah that's right
yeah it's a fair assessment and you know
you're you're you're certainly
you know once getting the the
quarterback and having him
you know young quarterback franchise
quarterback having him locked away
it it just allows a lot of flexibility
because you know the quarterback
obviously is is the ultimate band-aid
and he makes receivers look good and
linemen look good and
defensive stay off the field so you know
you have a sense of
you can attack the way you want to
construct this in a little bit more of a
creative way
um but certainly you're always going to
want to protect him and i think
we all saw that this offseason what we
did with our offensive line and we
dedicate a ton of resources to that but
i think once you have that guy and you
protect him i think
you know some of the other aspects of
ross building you can have a little bit
more
creativity with that's right in terms of
that line also just to wrap it up with
you brett veach kyle long
you got him back out of retirement and
i'm assuming dr duvernay tardif
returns in 2021 for you yeah that's
correct
you know both kyle and ldt and we
drafted um
lucas niang from tcu last year kid we
had
high hopes for he opted out last year so
both larry and lucas return
from um you know from from sitting out
last year
uh kyle's back and i'll tell you what i
know you guys all know kyle man he is a
ball of energy he is
in the building at 6 00 a.m and i think
when i leave at five o'clock at night
he's still in the building
and um he is fired up ready to go he's
in phenomenal shape
um you know then throwing him in the mix
with joe tooney orlando brown and then
crete humphrey the rookie we drafted
from oklahoma i think it's going to be
really exciting a lot of competition and
i know that pat's gonna
gonna feel well protected this year back
in the pocket brett thanks for the call
really appreciate it um good luck with
the rest of the schedule that i'll find
out later on
with america unless i see it on twitter
first so thank you very much i
appreciate it just
just shoot erica text and you'll be well
taken care of at eric stone street i'll
do that thanks brett appreciate it
you'll be welcome
take care that's brett beats general
manager hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here